Britain,
Britain had a real problem in the 1990s
because it basically allowed a number of
radical clerics,
especially for very key crap clerics to
operate within the country.
Um,
Abu Hamza,
I was one of them,
advocate tater and other Omar Bakri
another and these clerics were allow us
to operate,
um,
to give Simon's,
to radicalize youngsters,
to travel up and down the country,
address thousands of followers and some
of those followers then join up with,
with,
with al Qaeda became involved in suicide
bombings,
um,
cause real problems to the British
authorities in the period afterwards.
And certainly by either expelling some
of them or imprisoning other others of
them that that problem has been reduced.
The radicals now being driven much more
underground in the United Kingdom at
which,
which poses all sorts of other concerns,
but at least there isn't this a radical
message being put out in the open
anymore,
um,
in the UK.
And so that,
that,
that has changed the,
the,
the climate too to a degree in the
United Kingdom.
Um,
and you're starting really to see a push
back against the radicals amongst,
um,
all sorts of constituencies within the
Muslim community.
Um,
people who,
who wants,
had some sympathy,
um,
with,
uh,
some of archive has goals in the very
least,
and now going around mosque and they're
saying,
you know,
don't be any part of this,
this,
this ideology is not Islamic.
And,
and said,
you're seeing people,
um,
who were once involved with some of
these movements now tony against them
and I sort of push back happening
against the radicals.
And the key thing there was the July
seven,
2005 alcaide or attack on the London
subway system,
which really woke up a lot of them was
in community,
um,
in,
in Britain to the threat of alcaide are,
and turn some people who add at least a
little bit of sympathy with what some of
our Kyler was doing around the world.
And certainly in Iraq and Afghanistan,
a away from the organization.
Uh,
it was a sort of polarizing a event.
Um,
it's,
it,
it really turned vast majority of
Muslims fully against al Qaeda in the
country.
Um,
but of course,
the people who were already radicalized,
some of them became a even more
fervently radicalized by that event,
energized by that event.
Certainly,
um,
the,
the four suicide bombers,
uh,
amongst the small radical fringe of seen
as heroes.
I've,
I've had people come up to me and say,
Mahabir city ECOM is a blessing.
Marta.
Um,
you know,
who's going to go to paradise?
That they see him as an example.
Some of them unfortunately,
might want to follow in his footsteps.
Um,
but for the vast majority of Muslims,
and even for some wisdom to had some
sympathy for some of Alcaide as goals,
um,
that was an event really made them wake
up and turn against,
um,
the,
the radicals.
Uh,
so July seven was very important,
uh,
in London,
um,
in really,
starting up or off an opposition against
this ideology.
Um,
and,
um,
changing the climate.